another Trend that I have seen in
society is this trend of women older
women especially to write music that
really denigrates men and they want to
be a man I swear to Jesus that a lot of
these women want they they think to
themselves why wasn't I born a man every
day every day and I see this because
they make songs that sound like
something a guy would say um okay let me
let me let me show you this chick is
going viral on Tik Tok and I hate it
because her songs are actually a little
bit catchy like I kind of I kind of
bought my head slightly but listen to
the lyrics and let's let's just pull it
up thank God I break up with my ex cuz
Mama didn't raise no she didn't
raise a woman just to take a man's
said I could have it all if I really
think big got to focus on the back now
the boys will be up on my dick Mama
didn't raise no dummy no falling for a
man who's still living with his mommy I
can bake my own bread I can make my own
money so I won't be a nice pretty wife
you won't get a than